[Music]
okay our next speaker probably doesn't
need an introduction
um but i was told i'm supposed to
introduce people so i'm gonna do it um
it's joe chang he is the cto of our
studio and he is the
original creator of shinee and today
he's going to be talking about
styling shiny apps with assassin
bootstrap 4.
thanks winston yeah today we're going to
talk about styling shiny apps
and uh i'm going to start by talking
about the current state of the world
when it comes to
styling shiny so here are some of the
approaches that i personally have seen
people using
the first and probably most common
approach to styling shiny apps is to not
do it just accept the defaults
and honestly how many of us are just
happy it works at all
yeah so this is probably
the simplest possible example of a shiny
app but even that you know it's
something presentable you can show it to
your co-workers
and certainly as of 2012 when shiny was
new this was pretty uh
exciting and modern looking uh less so
in 2020
and you can take that lack of styling
pretty far i mean this is a
an app called radiant by vincent nyes
and it is using
only the default style and he's able to
do quite a lot with this app
today i'm going to focus on this example
app this is an evolution of an app that
i use for talk last year
i'm not going to get into the
functionality but i've
made it look a little bit different than
a regular shiny app or the most common
kinds of shiny app in terms of structure
but the styling is still the same this
is the default
style i haven't changed any of the fonts
or colors or anything like that
so shiny's default ui is powered by
bootstrap which is not a piece of
software that we created it was created
originally at twitter and is now
independent and this is one of the most
popular pieces of software in the world
today
it is the number six most popular github
project by stars across
all of github and it was designed to be
easily customized
but easily customized by web designers
they weren't thinking of our users
unfortunately
and this is an example of what bootstrap
looks like this is an example from
bootstrap's documentation
of just a simple page and there are a
lot of things
um about this page that uh i mean it
looks nice maybe a little bit generic
but this is that same page
with the one change of bootstrap being
removed it looks like this
so you can see that the amount of work
that bootstrap is doing
for us is substantial it's taking care
of typography
it's doing layout there are buttons and
nav bars
and search uh all of that are components
that come
with bootstrap along with these
different colors
so that's that first approach it's just
accepting the defaults
and i'm sure many people here how many
people here
are developing shiny apps or have
developed a shiny app okay quite a few
of you
and how many of you have just accepted
the defaults and and shipped apps
okay um so the the second approach is
maybe you're not happy with the complete
default look you just want to punch it
up a little bit you know
and uh one way to do that is to use a
prefabricated theme
such as the ones that come with shiny
themes the shiny themes package
so this again is that generic example
with
cranwells and with a single argument to
fluid page you can
apply a different theme and you can see
the colors change the fonts changed
the spacing has changed very slightly
some capitalization and
all that is accomplished by just that
one argument
and there are a few i don't maybe one or
two dozen different themes that are
available
and you know there's some variety there
but you're
making sort of an all or nothing choice
so you
if you like one of these great but
you're going to take the entire style
that that offers you and there's not
really a lot of
handholding it does to customize it on
top of that so this is that second
approach is
uh you you want uh it just to look a
little bit different
you might also want it to look a lot
different and a lot of people i think
are doing that these days how many
people here are using something like
shiny dashboard shiny material
a different oh my gosh okay so quite a
lot of you and
i think this took us a little bit by
surprise because we had created
shiny dashboard at our studio in order
to actually create dashboards and then
to see what people are using it for
which is almost everything that people
build with shiny apps
has been surprising but i think it was
because people just want a different
look
than the default that's a lot of knots
okay so this is shiny dashboard
this is a shiny material that by eric
ray anderson that makes
things look more googly i guess um
and then this is uh from the r interface
project
an argon based ui toolkit and shiny was
always designed to do this it was always
designed to let people use things
besides our defaults
and so that's a great option but what it
doesn't do
necessarily is provide this capability
which is you want specific
fonts colors and styles i'm going to
come back to this in a moment
but um i think we all if who have tried
to do this can agree
shouldn't this be easier than it is
today with uh with shiny definitely
requires a lot of custom
css and uh before i start talking about
that i just want to give a nod
to this last approach which is native
html i'm not going to talk much about
this today
but you do always have the option to
forego
most of chinese ui layout css style and
do
your own thing or work with a web
designer who can do this for you
let r do what r is good at and let html
and css designers do what they're good
at
uh this is an example of an app i wrote
a few years ago that
this is all powered by shiny all of
those numbers the plots are
outputs that are driven by shiny but the
entire front end is constructed using
html and css
so that is a possibility but that's not
what i want to focus on today
the thing i want to focus on today is
this right
why is that funny uh how can i get my
shiny app to match the official fonts
and colors of my company
um i get this question a lot i get it
from
our customer success people i get it
from people at conferences
and maybe for you it's not your company
maybe it's your client maybe it's your
university
or whatever it is you might have some
reason to to prefer a
specific set of fonts and colors and
this seems like it's something that
should be pretty easy
and it turns out that it's not and um
this i hope will be the most painful
demo that you'll see here at our studio
conf
uh here again is my app and uh
our designer greg sent me
this uh color and font
branding guide for our studio and i want
to take this cran wheels app and make it
look less generic and more r studio-ish
so the first thing i want to do is i
want to take this
bright blue and change this to this
accent orange which has a hex color of
whatever it is so i'm going to do this
the way you would
do this today by writing more css okay
i've already created the css file
and
if you are uh if you have some
experience with web stuff
you've done this before you use the
inspector to figure out
what kind of a selector you might want
to write and
because i did this for many years i can
tell you that that is the right
incantation for this
everybody following along with that
okay great so that caller changed um it
took me a lot longer than that to do it
the first time but
uh sure enough that works um
but uh these links let's let's update
those links as well right
so i'll say those are navs that are not
active
and instead of changing the foreground
color i mean the background color i'm
not going to change
the foreground color
okay now you might think you're done but
actually there are a few things missing
uh if i scroll down
there's a link here at the bottom that's
still blue
uh if i hover over these uh
oh when i hover over these links they're
supposed to turn like a slightly darker
shade and it doesn't do that
and if i click on i don't know if you
can see it with the projector but when i
click on a control
a focus ring is drawn and that also is
this blue color and i want to replace
all of those with orange
and uh the point is i'm just trying to
replace one color here
and i'm already falling into this rabbit
hole of having to
hunt down one little edge case after
another and write css to overwrite it
all
so uh this is not a great
status quo that we're living in today
so why is this so difficult why does it
take so much effort to just override one
color this
is bootstrap css i don't know if you
guys can back it you know what
just uh there is there's a color that's
being highlighted uh there's a hex code
and this is the source code for
bootstrap's css
so this is saying that this link should
be blue that very specific shade of blue
this color appears all throughout the
css file
25 different times and some of them are
pretty complicated
so if you as a shiny app author want to
change all of those instances of blue to
that specific
shade of orange you would actually have
to override each one of those rules with
custom css and those are
pretty complicated selectors that we're
looking at here
so clearly this is not really a tenable
strategy
for changing colors and in fact imagine
if you're not a shiny app uh author but
instead
you are you are the people maintaining
bootstrap i just gave away the punchline
um if if you are the developer of
bootstrap
i mean how much more painful is it for
you as you're working on this framework
and uh it turns out that that is not
what people do people do not do search
and replace 25 times to change colors
instead professional web developers use
a language called sas instead of css sas
is css plus uh super powers
i mean i guess it's super power to go
they're not that exciting but
they're going to help us a lot today
here you can see
on the left we've got sas which is
css plus additional features and the
feature that we care about for today's
purposes
is sas has the ability for you to
declare and use variables
so instead of hard coding this color
throughout the css you write sas code
that declares a variable called primary
assigns it that color blue and then
everywhere in your sas
code you use that variable instead of
the hard-coded color
now browsers don't understand sas so you
have to run that sas
source through a sas compiler and
you result in the styles.css that
replaces the variable with its value
you get the picture um and really this
sas compiler is where we lose
our users most of the time because we
are now talking about a tool chain that
they are not familiar with and not
really interested in using
but the point i want to get across is
that bootstrap
was designed from the beginning for you
to replace this color
right they centralized in their sas code
the
that blue color into one variable and
then that variable is used throughout
their
uh sas source the upshot of this
is that as our users if we could set
those bootstrap
variables if we could override the
values of those variables from r
then we could bend bootstrap to our will
we could just say i want primary to be
orange and we would be done
so to that end we've developed two new r
packages that i'm talking about today
well i'm not going to talk about sas but
sas is the foundation
that bootstrap lib is built on sas is
a way to compile sas to css directly
from r but we've built these higher
level tools
specifically for bootstrap in bootstrap
lib so we're not going to be
um you're not going to need to interact
with sas in order to use bootstrap lib
and the rest of my talk i'm mostly going
to be focusing on
bootstrap lit bootstrap lib uh you can
think of it as our bindings for
bootstrap it's designed to be used not
only from
for shiny even though we're just going
to be talking about shiny today but you
can also use it with our markdown with
html widgets
anywhere else in r where you might want
to use bootstrap
you can customize and re-customize
bootstrap straight from within r
and uh it also basically bundles in what
used to be the separate package of shiny
themes
this is functionality that's included in
bootstrap live
and i'm very excited to show you this so
this is how you use it this is a typical
shiny app
um first you load the library
second you call bs theme new and this
declares that you are starting a new
theme
uh it's kind of equivalent to calling
plot.new
step 3 you set whatever customizations
you'd like
in this case i'm setting the body
background color to pink and the
that primary link color to maroon and
then finally you call the function
called bootstrap
to build a custom build of bootstrap
that uh obeys those
variables and inserts it into whatever
ui you're calling it from so in this
case
this fluid page is going to have a
bootstrap dependency custom built for it
and
and injected
so let's take a quick look at that
so i'm going to take this cran wells app
again and i've already done three of
those steps so i've
library bootstrap lib is here i'm
calling bs theme new
and i'm calling bootstrap bootstrap
so now all i need to do is add a
variable
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to change that primary color
to that orange and let's run the app
and sure enough with that one change
the links are orange this is orange the
link at the bottom is orange
if i click on this uh selector or this
uh this text input
the ring around it is orange so
everywhere in those 25 instances of blue
those are now orange
but let's go a step further and let's
take this gray dark
gray background and change that to our
studio dark blue
so that is called secondary
is someone oh increase the font size
i didn't know if that voice was coming
from inside my head it's
so faint yes mother
sorry um here lenny
make that bigger yeah so bs
theme ad variables primary and secondary
and that's all we need to do
which let's be honest isn't that kind of
what you expect from shiny in the first
place like shouldn't it always have been
just like two variables
okay uh which if you're a skeptic
you might have been rolling your eyes a
little bit that i just knew that primary
and secondary were the names of those
variables so how do we know what
variables
to uh to type in uh so there are uh
links here to the variable list i'll
have a link to these again at the end
um so there are hundreds of variables
but they're very sensibly named in group
in the boot trap source code but in
addition we've written our own custom
documentation for you uh find folks in
the shiny community
that are more along the lines of things
that you might need to do and these
stocks will be evolving over time as
well
okay real quick um one other thing that
we have done to try to make this easier
for you is uh we've built a real-time
previewing tool
so instead of calling run app from shiny
we call
run with themer
and this launches that exact same app
but with this additional ui on the right
so
in this case uh like let's change the
background color to something ridiculous
um and within you know a second or so it
updates
so um let's change this to something
reasonable like
our studio official light gray
okay and then let's why don't we go all
the way and change the font to the uh
our studio font
okay so that's looking pretty good now
and what this tool does is it prints out
the source code that you need to make
this
permanent to the console so i'll just
copy this line
add it here and uh
the next time i run this app without run
with themer
you can see that it is updated
thank you the one person who clapped
i know i wasn't okay i'll take it i'll
take it yeah
okay uh so just one one other thing
and not in a steve jobs fight it's
literally just one more thing uh
now one thing that's always bothered me
personally about uh any time i try to
punch up my shiny apps
everybody likes dark mode right that's
cool but look at the background of this
gg plot it looks ridiculous
right the white around it just kind of
throws off the whole
effect so uh what we've done
with the next version of shiny hopefully
assuming winston approves it
is um uh
a feature that you need to opt into
uh called plot auto colors
it's so hard to type when hundreds of
people are staring at you
okay with that one line of code
all right
i showed my wife she was not as
impressed
[Applause]
with that one line of code everywhere in
your application you have a gg plot
or a base plot or a lattice
we will try to apply some automatic
defaults based on the colors in your dom
and this is actually pretty
sophisticated and it has nothing to do
with bootstrap this is built into shiny
not bootstrap libs so you can take
advantage of this feature
when shiny ships it with any kind of ui
framework
including shiny dashboard flex dashboard
any of those others
okay so uh so those are the instructions
either you can set it
application wide with that shiny option
or you can pass
uh individual auto colors equals true to
render plot if you want to opt in
on a opt-in or out on a plot by plot
basis
okay before we get to questions i just
want to point out that
third-party packages that want to take
advantage of bootstrap and bootstrap lib
coloring they will have to be updated so
html widgets will need to be updated if
they want to take advantage of this
functionality
our markdown document formats um and
shiny extensions like shiny ds and shiny
widgets so
the ones of these that our studio
maintains we will take care of updating
and uh for the ones that are maintained
by third-party package
maintainers if you're in this room we
would love to work with you we would
love to support you as
as we try to get people onto this
infrastructure
i just want to acknowledge that
bootstrap lib
is built uh using both bootstrap 3 or
bootstrap 4 which is the first time that
rstudio has
uh has taken the plunge into bootstrap
4. i'm not going to talk much more about
this today unless people have specific
questions but
i just want to point out that that this
is laying the groundwork uh towards
moving
everything to bootstrap four which is
something that uh is going to happen
over the course of uh the next year so
finally i want to acknowledge number one
some prior art
uh we didn't know about this package
until we were pretty far along in the
development but there's a package from
the dreamars
organization called fresh that
accomplishes many of the same goals but
without the sort of benefit of being
the maintainers of shiny so um they i
think they've done some really clever
work that's very cool and it works with
a lot of packages already today
and i think because we're able to kind
of change things from the inside we're
able to achieve a slightly different
workflow
that uh hopefully will build a better
foundation for the future but i just
want to acknowledge that they've done
some excellent work there
and then sas was primarily implement
implemented by tim massney who was a
summer intern and bootstrap live was
mostly written by
carson steve which will be speaking next
on shiny meta
thank you
thanks joe that's great um thanks for
applying public pressure on
my ability to make a choice about it
um all right so let's get the questions
here
all right uh why is bootstrap live all
written in snake case
all written in snake case you know why
yeah uh yeah so uh why is it written in
state case uh
shiny was written in camel case because
um in in 2012 i think
um i didn't have strong opinions and i
was just kind of going by
what uh what i thought most people
wanted and i get that question a lot
like why aren't we moving everything to
snake case so it's very hard to move
shiny itself to snake case because of
backwards compatibility
but where we have the opportunity to
create brand new packages
um you know why not go with at least
what it seems to me like the shiny
community is asking for which is more
not only snake case but moving um to uh
sort of like input underscore select
instead of select input
uh do plot auto callers propagate to
plotly plots
no do plot there's no reason why they
couldn't um
but currently we've been focused on uh
on the static side of things yeah is
that right
yeah okay one more uh when will shiny
move to bootstrap four
uh yeah that was gonna be my entire talk
today
and then it turned out that the theming
stuff took all 20 minutes
uh it's it's going to be a process over
this year but we are intent on moving in
a way that does not break backwards
compatibility
uh so we uh i think we've landed on a
strategy
that is going to let us very organically
allow people to move to bootstrap for
um without ever breaking the promises
that we've made so i think it's
something that you'll you should expect
to see evolve over the next 12 to 24
months
thank you thanks a lot
[Music]